monsieur michel rocard vous êtes
secrétaire général du psu après monsieur
gaston defferre et monsieur alain savary
vous êtes depuis quelques heures un
candidat de gauche à la présidence de la
république pourquoi je ne suis pas
encore un candidat de gauche à la
présidence de la république
il a simplement été confirmée parce que
notre bureau national vient d'envoyer
aux parties le rapport sur lequel il va
délibérer que dimanche prochain nous lui
soumettrons la proposition de ma
candidature et cette décision est prise
dans la situation actuelle c'est à dire
dans l'état de ce que nous connaissons
l'impossibilité de discuter avec
l'ensemble des forces de gauche et
l'impossibilité de faire définir une
candidature qui réponde aux aspirations
que la plupart des français ressentent
quand à leur avenir
c'est ça notre problème dès que nous
avons su par exemple que la convention
des institutions républicaines invitait
tous les partis de gauche à se
rencontrer nous avons répondu oui que
nous étions prêts relais une telle
rencontre et elle n'a pas pu se tenir
et puis nous voyons un candidat de la
vème république est déjà au moins deux
de la quatrième république et nous avons
l'impression que toutes ces négociations
doute ces manoeuvres sont désespérément
classique est cependant se payer connaît
un malaise
il ya en france des difficultés
profondes le mois de mai les a révélés
profondément mieux que des années de
discussions mais ce ne sont pas des faux
problèmes
c'est ce qui ont provoqué le départ du
général il faut les résoudre il faut
leur trouver des solutions
nous pensons que ces solutions doivent
être socialiste et la proposition de
ma candidature si le parti devait la
retenir c'est la proposition que ces
solutions socialistes s'expriment mais
en même temps nous faisons un appel à
toutes les forces politiques et
syndicales qui considère qu'il n'y a pas
de réponse
actuellement aux problèmes qui se trouve
posée aux pays qui souhaitent qu'une
réponse socialiste soit donnée si cette
discussion là peut s'engager
effectivement ma candidature peut
trouver un autre sens ou disparaître
mais ce qui nous paraît nécessaire c'est
d'affirmer une certaine forme d'avenir